My name is Bill Durham. I'm Bing Professor in
Human Biology and Human Biology and Anthropology at Stanford University.
>> Well, we're really happy you're joining us especially to talk about a
very important concept. Now, we've been
learning about lactose intolerance and about the
idea that as all infants. We have the ability as mammals to digest
these lactose containing products. And as
we get older our lactate expression diminishes.
But in some people, the lactate gene sort of stays
on, and we continue to make lactates. And so we'll
start of by asking why in human evolution would something
like this happen? How could something like this even happen?
>> Well, from a pan-mammalian background where the
lactase activity peaks around birth and then tails
off quickly into the weaning period and into
adulthood. We assume, we know that that's pan-mammalian.
Even your house cat is lactose malabsorbed. A malabsorber
or lactose intolerant. at least every house cat that's
been tested is. Eve, even those people will give
milk to their house cats. And what we don't know
is whether the people have found the threshold or
the cat's found the threshold to avoid diarrhea and
other consequences. What's interesting then is from that background
of a peak, some human populations show persistent lactase activity,
into adulthood. While the majority continue to
decline. So it's that minority of lactose
tolerant adults that are really fascinating. It's
a wonderful question because here's a case where
you have interest specific polymorphism. You have
existence and if the ongoing persistence of a
genetic difference between human populations. With regard
to some relatively simple trait and a trait
that has to be relatively recent in human history.
>> Sure.
>> There were no sources of milk prior to dairy
animals. So what we have here is, I mean other
than mother's milk there were no mammalian sources of milk
for human population before agriculture and so here we have.
>> Right, there's this, right, I was going
to wonder too, you know, the idea that. I
mean, are we the only species that actually
drinks the milk from another species as, as well?
>> I'm not aware of any species that makes
a habit of drinking the milk of another species. I'm aware of infants of,
a particular, an infant of a particular mother, nursing from
another mother. That happens in pinnipeds; it happens in several mammals. It's
considered milk stealing. and obviously, there's
great reward to the successful pup, but,
I'm not aware of another case where, especially,
where infants or adults drink milk from another
mammal. That's a, that's a good question, I
really don't, just don't know an answer to that.
>> so we have this scenario then as you mention where we have this sort of
minority of people who, instead of having lactase
expression diminish over time it's, it's, it's persistent lactase.
>> Persistent lactase activity into adulthood. Uh-huh.
>> Sure. Now, you mention that it seems to be relevant
specifically because of the recent evolution of this trait.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Because the domestication of dairy.
>> Uh-huh.
>>
>> So we assume that the pan-mammalian background means that at the dawn
of history human populations were all
lactose intolerant. And that there would be
at best a mutationally low frequency
of individuals that varied on that characteristic.
And because it was a very low variation, and there was no milk
available, we would have no way of knowing how
much there was, or how often it recurred and
so on. But what we have then in the
meantime is this great invention called agriculture. The domestication of
plants and animals at the service of the human
food supply. We have every reason to believe that the
main animals that are used for milk today, were
originally domesticated for meat. They were valued first for meat,
and that milk was as the, expression goes,
were part of a secondary products revolution. Where
they realized that you could use more than
the meat from these animals, goats, sheep, you
know, cattle and so on. And so, they
already probably had them in close association with
human communities, they were probably already harvesting the
meat regularly. They probably had mastered overwintering, water supply,
herding activities, and that sort of thing. And
then suddenly there's evidence for using the, the
milk product of these animals. some of the
earliest evidence comes from Sahara rock paintings that
are dated to 4500 B.P. that show, in
fact, bringing the calf up, near the female,
the adult female. And human being underneath. Now
we infer that the human being underneath is doing
this, what else is a human being doing under a cow?
>>
[LAUGH]
>> But that's some of the earliest
evidence, and what's interesting is that they bring
the calf up, to trigger the letdown reflex in the, in the cow so that
the humans can take the milk. And to this day, farmers will tell you, there's
lot of ways to induce that reflex. But one of them is bringing the calf up.
>> That makes so much sense.
>>
[INAUDIBLE].
>> It's like a woman hearing a baby cry in a department store.
>> Absolutely, yeah.
>> And she starts lactating.
>> huh, yep. Absolutely, same thing. And
so, It's clear, then. Or we surmise, from
this history, that, milk was valued. Or that
cattle were valued first. For beef, or for
their meat product, and then later for
milk. Milk was a secondary product. It wasn't
very effective. And the question then became, well
what was the advantage of milk on top
of the meat? If you've already got an addition
to your food supply, why is it that milk suddenly
is valuable? That's triggered the most debate and the, and
the most interesting research, I think. now the question really
was, what was the added value. Of drinking fresh milk?
It's complicated on the one hand, because you had the
meat value of these animals you domesticated. So, it seems
unlikely that it would be just protein or food supply,
yet that was an important early argument. And
the question, and, and, it's also complicated because
There are ways to get some food value from milk without drinking it fresh. You
can all societies that I know of have ways of processing fresh milk.
Into low lactose forms. Sour milk is a low lactose form. All the things like
yogurt and kefir. Drinks that are widely known in some places. And most cheeses.
>> Mm hm.
>> Break down the lactose
externally, using lactobacillus bacteria. Using a separation of curds and whey.
Lactose is water soluble. It drains off with the whey, and the
curds are free of lactose. So most cheeses have very little
lactose concentration, something like yogurt is
full of lactobacillus that's already digesting
>> Sure.
>> The lactose for human consumption. So here's the real challenge.
In a world where most populations. Huh, sorry. In a world where most populations
have ways to process milk and to get everything that's in the milk.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Why would some populations still evolve this persistent lactase activity?
>> Sure.
>> Because there are external sources of lactase,
why does it have, why, what was the advantage
of producing it internally to the human organism? And
that's the question that I focused on early on
because I thought that was just so very fascinating.
On top of the food value, on top of
whatever you can get from yogurt and kefir and
cheese and sour milk. Wh-, what, what's the advantage
of drinking fresh milk as an adult? Especially when
so many societies must have regarded it as repugnant,
because it would cause diarrhea.
>> Sure.
>> To humans, it was. You're intolerant. And
you know, the debate is still running. But
the theory, the leading theory that I like,
is the, and that the data seems to support,
you know in science knowledge is always tentative.
So I want to put that out there, and,
you know, I will sound like I'm convinced
of this but, you know, I think we're all
maintaining a healthy skepticism. But the leading argument
of the day is that calcium. That the advantage
of drinking fresh milk is the advantage of an
additional calcium supply, especially in areas where there is
a calcium deficiency caused either by inadequate calcium in the
diet. Well, that's not too likely if you're being, drinking milk.
>> Sure.
>> but a vitamin D scarcity. Vitamin D is
in turn photosynthesized in the skin in response to sunlight.
So that immediately suggested to me the possibility that
as you depart from low latitudes of high ultraviolet light,
you would encounter chronic built-in geospatial curves of. ultraviolet
light deficiency and therefore a vita-, which is what's required for.
>> Sure.
>> Vitamin D synthesis. And therefore Vitamin D scarcity with latitude.
>> Now we learn actually in lesson six of our course. We go
and learn about mutation and variation, and
we use skin pigmentation as an example.
>> Oh, perfect!
And so this is parallel.
[CROSSTALK]
So my hypothesis is that this was
completely parallel. In fact in Co-evolution, the
book that that I written on this,
I have an appendix on epidermal demelanization. to
show the efficacy of the altitudinal gradient.
In ultraviolet light, and vitamin D, and in
calcium based selection for epidermal demelanization, so
I like that as a background, and I'm
just saying, look if it's plausible there, look at the
argument we can make here. And then people say, what's the
advantage, milk is obviously rich in calcium, but what's the
advantage of having, why can't you again just eat the yogurt?
>> huh.
>> And why can't you again just eat the milk
product, the cheese? Which is going to have the calcium in
it. Except for the water soluble calcium, which you might
lose some of. What's interesting was some research on what's
called the lactose effect. If you feed human infants from birth in a controlled
comparison cow's milk, from birth, or mother's
milk, versus soy milk, you see beginning
in a matter of a few days, You see a big differential in the amount of
bone absorbed calcium. In other words the calcification of bone is enhanced.
You can, this is controlling for the amount of
calcium. You take soy milk and you supplement the calcium
in it so that it matches the cows milk. They
have the same calcium and the presence of the lactose
enhances the absorption of the calcium according to this, these
data. Now, it's a magnificent curve and if what it
shows is that the ability to drink fresh milk has
the advantage of making the calcium that's there an equal
proportion in the two milks That makes it more available, to the infants who can
absorb who can digest the lactose. there's a
mechanism suggested for this. It has to do
with the transphosphorylation of of one of the
opening up of a calcium channel. In the,
in the jejunal region of the brush border
membrane cells, the jejunal region of the small
intestine, and that it's the removal of a blocking phosphate that, on to
the splitting lactose molecule that opens up the channel And that lul-, the
presence and the, and the breakage of the lactose molecule opens the channel
for the entrance of the calcium. So that lactose is like vitamin D.
>> And so, and just to be clear, it's
not even, maybe not per se the lactose itself,
but the lactose, the action of lactose metabolism.
>> Correct.
>> It enhances the calcium uptake.
>> Now I have to ask you.
>> So that's like wild, because that's
like saying, okay, they work differently. VItamin
D works by enhancing calcium binding protein
which actively absorbs it, but it's in both
cases, the action of the Vitamin D mechanisms brush border cells of the jejunum
of the small intestine and so is the lactose effect. Right there in the same.
Epithelial lining. So it's pretty exciting actually and it suggests then that
one reason that infants don't need a lot of sun exposure at least to the best
of my knowledge, is that they have the
lactose effect at the same time as they have.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that those people who have the gene for
persistent lactase activity continued to enjoy the lactose effect in those
years all the way out for the persistent lactase activity.
So what's particularly interesting about that is that it's saying that
lactase persistence compensates for the vitamin D deficiency
>> Mm hmm
>> That's built into the solar radiation pattern on the surface of
our Earth. So that milk, like
epidermal demelanization, they follow similar curves.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that you get the persistent lactase
activity, and lac, lactose tolerance at high latitudes.
>> Right, and
so just to sort of re-word what you say here
to make sure, you know, we're clear on this. In the
case for skin pigmentation, as you sort of alluded to,
the idea is, as human migration moved away from the equator.
>> Yeah.
>> To higher and I guess even, I guess we should also say lower latitudes.
>> Yes.
>> They had less sunlight, and so they had to.
>> Well, you can say higher latitudes north and south.
>> Sure. Higher latitudes north and south. they lost pigmentation
in the skin because they needed to let more sunlight in for Vitamin D.
>> There was selection for the entrance of
more sunlight. It wasn't that they recognized a need.
>> Yes, exactly.
>>
[LAUGH]
The same with milk. It wasn't that we are sitting
around here. Wow, hoping and wishing we could have another
source of calcium. What's happening is that those that happened.
To have this out-reproduced by. You can even test whether
it's a 3%, a 2%, a 5%. How much does
the difference have to be in the long run in
terms of differential survival and reproduction in order for this
to work out in the time frame that we have
from 4500 years BP or whatever? And I'm one of those who thinks that it's a
pretty small advantage. Pretty small advantage, but persistent
generation after generation, no fail. It's there. If
you have the lactose mechanism for absorbing calcium
and making strong bones less likely to have
Rickets. Less likely to have Harrison Sulcus. Less
likely to have broken bones in young adulthood.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And all those things you'll have that rigid calcification of bone
which you can see starting right out in infancy with the lactose effect.
>> I mean that, that's amazing, can you give us
some idea, maybe about, the time scale that it spread on
>> Mm hmm
>> And also, some maybe idea of the, the rate
of the spread. As well, as the point of origin geographically.
>> Yeah, so what we understand today, I'm drawing mostly on the work
of Sarah Tishkoff a geneticist who has looked at the
question of origins, first of all, we think there are
multiple. I like to call it the big L gene.
So I'm going to just use that. It's almost slang for me.
>> Sure.
>> It's not that technical name, but it makes it easy for persistent. We use.
>> We use L plus and minus
>> Okay
>> So we do plus and minus.
>> Alright, I'll. L plus is persistent lactase activity?
>> Exactly.
>> Alright. So L plus. And what she shows is that no all L plus genes
are the same.
>> Really?
>> Yup. And that there are at least
four different origins of the big O. Of the
O plus gene. and they're broken up by
different language families. So we're pretty clear that they
had an independent origin. But the selection pressure
is strong enough. So there's a northern European one,
and then it turns out that there are some
on the equator in milk dependent pastoral peoples where
the advantage of drinking milk might not have to do with
calcium at all. It might have to do with water availability, fluid
availability, electrolyte availability. If you live in a desert And you've got
this cow who can concentrate for you from sparse vegetation and dew.
>> hmm.
>> Into a drinkable, water-based product.
There's a huge advantage especially during
drought seasons and so on, so it's quite
possible that those genes had a different selection pressure.
>> That's amazing. So, I mean, so we just learned also about
the concept of an allele. And I hear you use the word gene.
>> huh.
>> And just to clarify for us, we
would say there are four different lactase persistent alleles.
>> Yes, there is.
>> We discussed one in particular.
>> huh.
>> that's actually. Is reported in personal
genetics reports at places like 23andMe, but, so it's very interesting
that there are multiple other alleles that could cause lactase persistence.
>> It, it's not clear to me that, that the,
that the instruction in the gene itself is different, but
the genetic environment is different enough so that there are
markers to show us that it had a different origin.
>> Right.
>> Which is, which is a, a really compelling,
>> Now you said there are possibly four different alleles that allow for this.
>> That's correct.
>> And
there's, you mentioned a higher latitude origin, and then
even an origin in milk dependent populations near the equator,
>> That's correct.
>> Are there two other origins as well? Or are those?
>> There are three near the equator, and then there's
the one that has evolved to high frequency in northern Europe.
>> And so is the one from northern Europe the most dominant?
>> The most dominant in the sense, they're all dominant genes.
>> Well, prevalent, I should say.
>> They, they reach very parallel, very parallel frequencies.
They reach very high frequencies both in these
milk-dependent pastoral populations in the deserts of the equator.
>> hmm.
>> The Sahara Desert and surrounding environment. And then the peoples who
live at high latitude in, you
know, Denmark. What's today Denmark and Scandinavia
in northern Europe. So the frequencies are comparable. Which is interesting, but
not too surprising if a, we've had 4500 years for this to evolve.
And b, if you have re, relentless selection pressures
because of the advantage of calcium, or the advantage of
electrolytes and water. those are both pretty compelling problem, pressures.
I don't know, I've spent some time in the desert.
[LAUGH]
And I find it very convincing. If you're out
of water in the desert, life is tough, yeah.
And a cow is a wonderful device for giving
you water if the wells are dry. If the fields.
>> Sure
>> The crops failed, amazing to think that a cow might be a water tank
in the, in the, it might be a calcium device in the north, and a water tank.
>> Yeah.
>> at the Equator.
>> Even if there are negative side effects and you're not.
>> Absolutely
>> Completely tolerant, I mean it's worth it for the hydration.
>> but they are, you see, that's again,
they've evolved the high frequency of the gene
of lactase persistence. Now, it's true, not everybody.
Not everyone in the society, the gene is
not at fixation, as we would say. It's not at 100%. But for the small number
of people who have diarrhea now there's another,
this is this is where I come back
to the difference between intolerance and absorption because you
can take a malabsorber. So in a population of these
pastoralists, living on the equator with a gene that
is not a fixation, some people aren't going to produce
lactase. And, so therefore, you expect them to be
intolerant but what's a really interesting thing if you look
in the legal documents in the last few years, someone
in the US has taken a patent. On a process
for converting intolerant individuals to tolerance
without changing their genetics. And the way
it goes is that you keep giving them the low dosage of milk a
long enough time. They suffer diarrhea, diarrhea,
diarrhea until their intestinal microflora change. And
the result is they become tolerant malabsorbers.
Now their genes haven't changed. They still
lack lactase. They can't produce lactase. But now they're tolerant.
So guys have already taken out a patent on this, which
was in fact in the folklore in a number of
places, that if you. Could grin and bear it for awhile.
>> You, yeah.
>> Drinking milk you could induce tolerance in yourself.
You could make yourself. You could go from being
tolerant and feeling bloated and diarrhea and all that.
You could come out the other end without those symptoms.
So it's possible that in fact, and even
in those societies where milk is so important
as an electrolyte source of electrolytes in water,
it's possible that what they've done is introduced, most
people are lactose absorbers, and that would help
with, the, for the majority of the population. And
it's possible that they induce tolerance in the
malabsorbers. Now, I'm speculating, because I haven't tested that.
>> No. I mean, it even sounds reasonable. Because 23andMe and
other places will report. They'll give you your genotype.
And they will say, likely tolerant, or likely intolerant.
>> Exactly.
>> Because they're also aware of the gut microbiota.
>> Absolutely.
>> That can essentially metabolize the lactose for you.
>> Exactly.
>> Now, I wanted you to mention.
>> Or buffer you. From the diarrhea effects
so that maybe you're not even getting, you
may not be getting the full food value,
but you're at least not getting the negative effects.
>>
>> Negative symptoms.
>> How, what proportion of the world is
considered to be lactose tolerant or not malabsorbers?
>> personally, I go with in, the figures vary
usually people put it between 70 to 80% lactose intolerant.
I would put it as 70, 80% lactose malabsorber,
because I don't really know about the, the, the symptomatics
of it. How many, how many people have the symptoms? and that it would therefore
be 20 to 30%, adult persistent lactase activity. Uh-huh.
>> And would we assume then that in
regions of the world particularly South America, maybe East
Asian Pacific Islands would be the areas where
we have the least amount of lactase persistent individuals.
>> And tropical
Africa in the zone where. Tsetse flies
discouraged cattle domestication. The geographer Fred Simuns
did a wonderful study years ago showing that the tsetse belt of Africa. there is
there are no lactose absorbers in that zone. That was one of his first clues.
Is that where the tsetse flies discouraged
cattle by the economic disadvantage of sick cattle.
>> Sure
>> Which isn't going to work because
they all have sleeping sickness and you can't make them
economically productive. There's no milk and there has been no
milk for as long as there has been tsetse flies
and the tripanosome, the parasite, that causes African sleeping sickness.
And that is a, a long history, a long time
ago. So, what Simoons went on to argue is that
this is an area, the tropical belt of Africa with
its tsetse fly. It really kind of spans the equator
in Tanzania and Kenya, and so on. There's a belt there that with the, with the
high-density of tsetse flies where, that it's never
paid to cultivate cattle, and they're lactose malabsorbers.
>> Gosh.
>> Fascinating, isn't it? because right nearby, outside
the tsetse zone, are the milk dependent pastoralists that
have high levels. So it's a wonderful example of
geography, culture, human history, and genetics all working together.
>> Perfect
for a biological anthropologist.
>> Yeah, perfect for
[LAUGH]
exactly. There's one more interesting case that's really fun to talk about.
>> Oh, yeah, I want to hear it.
>> And that's the Inuit.
>>
>> The Inuit are heavily melanized dwellers
of the arctic. They moved across the Bering Strait, sometime,
say, in the last 20,000 years, and there they are with darker skin than you'd
expect in the Arctic. And very low rates of rickets. Almost no rickets.
They also aren't lactose absorbers. So what do they do way up there in
the land of chronic vitamin D deficiency, very low ultraviolet? How
do they make it work? It turns out that before missionaries, they
had a practice of eating. Raw pinniped livers. Pinnipeds
in turn feed on cod and small fish like that that
non-photosynthetically generate vitamin D, and by eating enough of the
livers of the pinnipeds they concentrate the Vitamin
D from this non photosynthetic source. And so
they persisted with little evidence of selection against
epidermal melanization, and little evidence of selection for anything
like a milk tolerance and so on. And
what's so amazing is when missionaries came in and
said, oh my gosh that's barbaric, cutting up
a seal and eating raw liver for the delicacy?
That's disgusting, stop doing that. Rickets broke
out. So, what's so interesting? I mean,
an epidemic of rickets that was terrible,
crippling, for Inuit populations. What's so wonderful about
this example? It shows there's multiple ways to, to, to beat the rap on calcium.
Epidermal demelanization may work. The ability to
drink milk in adulthood may work. And harvesting
pinniped livers may work. And all of
these are interesting and diverse solutions to
this chronic problem built into our globe
of, of, of, calcium absorption, calcium deficiency.
>> that really is amazing. I want to ask you one
more question. being sort of thinking from the anthropological side
of things as well. What do you think of the
biggest consequences of a growing human population, with lets say even
20 to 30% that are able to metabolize, lactose because of lactase
persistence, are there any major cultural or other changes that have happened?
>> one of the most interesting consequences of the
discovery of adult lactose tolerance and intolerance which came about
in the 1960s in the US, was that we needed
to rethink our food aid. Can you imagine? We sent
thousands of pounds of dried powdered skim milk
to lactose malabsorbing adults all over the world.
It was food aid. Now if you stop
to think about it, that's like sending a laxative.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH]
>> Big bags of a laxative brought to you
by the friendly people of the United States of America.
>>
[LAUGH]
And this came to my attention before I
even heard of the phenomenon of lactose intolerance. I
was touring. I, I did some field in rural
El Salvador. I was working a tiny community called
[FOREIGN].
The mayor was taking me around town. Showing me
this is our grainary. This is our well. He took
me to the school house. And we walked in
and met the children. The teacher turned them out so
they could come out and sing a song for
me, or whatever. And then walked through the school, looking
at the very simple infrastructure of the school. And in
the corner were all these bags of donated US dried
skim milk. And I said
[FOREIGN]
why, why are the bags in the school?
Why aren't people using? Oh, don't worry he said
[FOREIGN]
don't worry, we do use the powder in those bags.
At least twice a year we get the comunity together.
People bring buckets. We'd put the bags. the powder in
the bags and water together when we whitewashed the schoolhouse.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> We were very grateful for the ability
to whitewash the school house. And I said but why, why, why, do you use it
as whitewash? He said, because the people here get sick if they eat that as a,
the intended food product. And you just imagine,
then, in the ethnographic literature, there's stories of
people in Bali, lining up to receive small
vials to put it in their family apothecary.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Family drug supply. If they ever need
a laxative, they can take U.S. food aid. But we sent thousands of
pounds a year of dried, powdered skim milk to a population where 80% are
lactose malabsorbers. As a general human population.
I think that's one of the least
exposed and, and most obvious gaffes, of
assuming that what's true in our society.
We have a high frequency of lactose malabsorbers
because of the Northern European population that was
important in the founding and, and the relative
growth rate compared to the Native Americans of
[LAUGH]
the United States, so we have a high,
relatively high frequency of lactase persistence. In adulthood.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And we assumed, oh just look at
the billboards and things we had. Everybody needs milk.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You never outgrow your need for milk.
Or remember that curve, you exactly do outgrow
your need for milk. And most adults do.
But yet, we had this cultural, let us say,
a cultural cocoon that said oh, people,
everybody needs milk. You never outgrow your need
for milk. Milk does a body good. We had all these messages, and so we started
shipping milk powder, thinking it was easy
to concentrate, Right? You can take milk and
make it dried skim milk. You could ship
it quickly. It stores well. The schoolhouse in
[FOREIGN]
I'm sure still has some in the corner
[LAUGH]
and people found lots of different ways to use it.
>> Wow.
>> Amazing.
>> That is an amazing story.
>> It is. And so what that helps you to realize is that.
it's important, I think especially important
for North Americans to open their eyes
and realize that what our genes encourage by way of cultural activities and,
and cultural environment is not necessarily the same for the rest of the world.
>> That's exactly right.
That's really all the questions I have. Is there anything else you would ask?
>> It's a classic example, you know. It's such a wonderful example of
the interplay of, of genes and of culture. we often use it for that.
>> Mm-hm
>> And model genes and cultures, two parallel tracks
and semi-independent tracks of inheritance. And what's so great is
in this particular case you can see how well
there's an environmental challenge coming through in lysine and calcium.
And you can see how you could change your culture and adopt
the drinking of pinniped livers and solve the problem. We can see how
you can evolve a high frequency of the big L gene and
solve the problem. Or you can live someplace, where that problem is less.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And and the problem is
actually, maybe protecting yourself against sunlight and,
and ultraviolet, and so therefore the high melanization. What I love is this,
this idea that, to understand the human organism,
you can't just study the genes. Or the culture,
you have to have 'em both on the table. And you have to think about both of
them. How they interact, how they may compensate
for one another, how they may influence one another.
Because a totally successful adaptation on the part of
demelanization would have. If it had been completely successful,
you would be not very likely to see the evolution of lactase persistence.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But it solved the problem. And what it shows you is that it helped. But
that, that there was, there is still a
recurring calcium deficiency at high latitude. Which we
know from records and, other things. So I just love this idea that the, the, the
study of the human organism involves thinking about
different kinds of inheritance and their interaction in time.
>> Thank
you so much.
>> Of course. Thank you.